down the ages past Allah sent his
Messengers to deliver humankind from
Darkness to light invite all to the way
of thy Lord with wisdom and beautiful
preachings and argue with them in the
ways that are best and most
gracious that's also the ongoing mission
of Islamic Research Foundation or irf
spreading the truth of Allah's final
message to
mankind founded in
1991 irf today offers some of the best
services and facilities in the world for
presenting an understanding of Islam in
an objective and scientific
way its programs are primarily focused
on correcting misconceptions and
promoting understanding of
Islam irf also imparts dawa training to
D to aply convey The Message of
Islam irf has one of the most modern
Studios producing program presenting
Islam which are beamed regularly on many
International TV channels in over 150
countries Dr Zakir Nik president of irf
reaching out across countries worldwide
from America to Europe to Africa to Asia
to Australia strives to clarify Islamic
viewpoints he dispels the many media
myths and anti-islamic prejudices
propagated the world over by
anti-islamic forces Dr Zakir Nik is a
medical doctor
he's acclaimed the world over for his
spontaneous and convincing replies to
questions posed by critics and
Skeptics during the question and answer
sessions after his
talks he is also renowned for his
verbatim quotes with references from
major religious scriptures of the
world Dr Zakir and other faculty of the
irf trained many dais in effective dawa
techniques
ir's website provides free dawa training
material for you to download and become
an effective Dai
yourself Dr zaker Nike's talks are
available on audio and video cassettes
CDs and DVDs the world
over irf today is creating a change in
the hearts and minds of millions of
Muslims and non-muslims worldwide
towards a proper understanding and
respect for Islam have a question or
doubt about Islam and its teachings now
you know one of the best Resource
Centers to get convincing answers from
is Islamic Research Foundation 5658
tandel Street North dri Mumbai
400009 India phone 2373
6875 fax 9122 2373 0689 email Islam at
the rate
of.net for more information log on to
our website www.
IR f.net Islam is misrepresented in the
media Islam is a religion of peace peace
to
humanity it does not only talk about
peace it
demonstrates
practically how peace and Universal
Brotherhood can be achieved we have one
common
parents and our
creator Allah subhana wa ta'ala almighty
God is one and the same one and the same
all
we have well-known and prominent speaker
Dr Zakir n who needs no
introduction he will be giving a lecture
on the topic peace vision of Islam why
this
[Applause]
event alhamdulillah
my dear brother
y brother Zakir
Ahmed brother Jeffrey my respected
elders and my and sisters I welcome all
of you with the Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of almighty
God be on all of
you I have been given the present
task of the inaugural
speech and talk about why this event
peace
a vision of
Islam today we
find that on the international
media whether it be the International
satellite
channels the international newspapers
the international
magazines the radio broadcast stations
there is virulent propaganda about
Islam Islam is misrepresented in the
media the main objective
of this exhibition peace a vision of
Islam is to present the correct picture
of
Islam to remove the
misconception from the minds of the
human beings and I started my
talk by quoting a verse of the Glorious
Quran from Surah is chapter number 17
verse number 81 which says
when truth is H against falsehood
falsehood perishes for falsehood is by
its nature bound to
perish
Islam comes from the root
word
Salam which means peace it is also
derived from the word s which means to
submit your will to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala that is almighty God so in short
Islam means peace acquired by submitting
your will to almighty
God and anyone who acquires Peace by
submitting his will to almighty God in
Arabic he's called as a
Muslim the misconceptions in the media
especially after the 11th of September
2001 has reached epidemic
levels and we find that this religion of
of
peace that is Islam is been labeled as
the religion of
terrorism the main objective of this
conference is to present the correct
picture of
Islam as you might have read the
brochure there are various Pavilions
there are various
events one of the major Islamic
exhibition consist
of about 275
posters the main objective
of these posters
is to present the picture of Islam so
that the human beings have an urge to
know more about this religion when you
read the newspaper there are
headlines if the headline is
attractive the person he reads the
newspaper and when you read an article
the first
paragraph it is a
synopsis of the
article which
holds the attention of the reader if the
first paragraph is not attractive the
reader stops reading further so the
first paragraph should be attractive so
that the reader is compelled to read the
article further so these posters mainly
the objective is to serve as
headlines or the first
paragraph the details are mentioned in
the various books which also exhibited
in the
exhibition for example
one of the posters it
mentions today's Gospel truths number
one Muslims are terrorists number two a
four-sided
triangle number three the Earth is
flat number four 2 + 2 is equal to
5 these are the gospel TS
today we know that how can a triangle
have four sides four-sided triangle it's
opposite similarly Muslims are terrorist
Muslim means a person who acquires Peace
by submitting his will to almighty God
so how can he be a terrorist these are
opposite as opposite as a four-sided
triangle as untrue as the is flat as
wrong as 2 + 2 is equal to
5 these posters serve as
headlines so that you you can read more
about Islam there are various
sections one of the sections in these
posters is of women in Islam the woman's
rights in
Islam and one of the posters it speaks
about the hijab that
is the
modest dressing for a woman and the
points are described in brief the
basically six points according to the
Quran and the Hadith
how women should be dressed the complete
body should be covered except the face
and the hands up to the wrist these many
scholarly also should be covered the
second is the clothes they
wear it should not be so tight so that
it reveals the figure it should be loose
third it should not be
transparent fourth it should not be So
Glamorous so that it attracts the
opposite sex fifth it should not
resemble that of the opposite sex and
six
it should not resemble and be a sign of
an
unbeliever in the talks that will follow
in this mega event peace to
humanity there'll be many International
speakers coming even speakers locally
we'll be giving talks on these
aspects and how to convince regarding
the modesty the hijab dress code of a
woman just by giving example
Suppose there are two twin
sisters both of them are very beautiful
equally beautiful and one twin
sister she is wearing the Islamic hijab
a complete body covered except the face
and hands up to the wrist and the other
twin sister she is wearing the western
clothes the mini skirt or shorts and if
both of them are walking down the
streets of chenai and around the corner
there is a holigan who is waiting for a
catch who's waiting to take te a girl
I'm asking the question which girl will
it tease will it tease the girl wearing
the Islamic hijab or will it tease the
girl wearing the Min skirts or
shorts but natural he will teach the
girl wearing the Min skirts or shorts as
Allah rightly says in Surah aab chapter
number 33 verse number 59 that oh
Prophet tell your wives and your
daughters and the believing women that
when they go abroad they should put on
the cloak so that they shall be
recognized and it will prevent them from
being
molested these posters that are
exhibited about 275 in number they act
as
headlines many of them they contain
verses of the
Quran and besides the English
translation it also contains the
translation of the regional languages
there are are models about 25 models
which present
the two picture of Islam for
example one model is of a
Quran and the verse mentioned below is
the verse of the Quran ofah Bak chapter
number two verse number 208 which
says oh you believe enter into Islam
wholeheartedly is if you want to enter
into Islam enter wholeheartedly not just
partly and the Quran has got various
Commandments and if a person only
follows a few
Commandments it is not appropriate and
the model shows that the Quran has got
seven strings and one rope where all the
strings are joined together as Allah
says in the Quran in Surah Al Imran
chapter number three verse Number
103 hold the Rope of Allah strongly and
be not divided we have to hold all
together the of Allah subhana wa tala
and enter into Islam
wholeheartedly if if you only follow one
aspect of Islam saying that okay I will
give charity but I will not pray I will
not perform the pilgrimage the Hajj it's
part of Islam or the other person may
say that I will perform the Haj but I
will not give
charity Allah says in the Quran almighty
God says that you have to follow
completely so if you hold the Rope the
complete rope all the command ments then
only will you get the true peace in this
world and the
Hereafter we believe that we should not
convey the message of Peace only to the
elders or to the
adults we should see to it that we
introduce the message of peace right
from the childhood and we find today
that in this materialistic
world the way our children
are being misled we have to take care of
our children it's the duty of every
parents to see to it that they give the
proper atmosphere to the
children today we
find
that the satellite
channels which has many children
programs we have video cassettes we have
films on the children we have cartoons
all of these
they don't actually convey the message
of peace and most of
them they speak about violence that's
the reason there are
psychologists in States and in the
European countries they say the maximum
Damage Done to the child is the programs
on the satellite channel and there are
various articles we read that a child in
the third standard he sees all these
warant movies once he has an argument
with his school friends he takes the gun
of his father and he shoots a couple of
them all this has been instilled in his
mind by what he sees what a child sees
it becomes part of his
nature when we tell to the people the
children that they should not see such
violent movies or movies that take you
away from peace we have to present
them with video cassetts which talk
about peace there are various Islamic
cartoons and animations which present
the true picture of Islam the true
picture of
peace
and it inculcates in the
child the nature which makes him
peaceful we have got various cartoons
various animations especially catering
to the children from the age of 3 to
12 there are audio cassettes for
children and most of the audio cassett
that are there for the nursery level and
for the pre- primary level they don't
have a
message for example I remember in school
we had learned the poem baa black ship
have you any wool yes sir yes sir three
bags full one for my master one for my D
and one for my person who lay down the
rail then we had Jack and Jill went up
the hill to fetch a pale of water fine
these have a certain message that teach
you new words but you find while you're
being taught new English
words we find the basic meth jackangel
is talking about a friend a boyfriend a
girlfriend going to a hill a baba black
sh talking about a DME in that a
child gets programmed that fine it's
good to be with girls girl and boy can
be together and they can enjoy have
friends in fact our children should get
the proper message of Peace there the
audio cassettes Islamic audio cassettes
songs such
as various songs collect from different
parts of the world from States from UK
from Singapore from Malaysia it speaks
for
example I am very strong I'm very strong
I love Allah he is my best friend anyway
my voice is not good I hope brother YF
Islam was here he' have given a better
demonstration so these poems and Islamic
songs I very strong I love Allah he is
my best friend so all these besides a
child learning new words he comes closer
to his creat Allah subhana wa ta'ala
there are various
songs for example the children of the
world where it shows how Islam brings
all the various children of the world
from Africa from States from UK from
Singapore from Malaysia how does it get
them together there are
songs which speak about animals they are
Muslims too so let's watch what we do
let's do what we can for the creatures
of Islam here the child is learning that
the animals they are also Muslims they
are creatures of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
we have to love them we have to respect
them we should not hurt them
irrespective whether they're big or
small whether they're shot at all so
these songs besides a child his
vocabulary increasing he comes closer to
the message of
peace I remember when I was a kid in the
late '70s and the early ' 80s how a
child you know wants to learn a computer
so we have a toy computer and you press
a button and my friend I remember he had
a computer you press a button and the
song comes beat it whatever it was of
Michael Jackson of that time or funky
town here there are computers for
children the moment you press button
number one you hear the voice of Imam
sesh
[Music]
alhamdulillah anyway I'm not
a so you had a child besides getting
entertained he is coming closer to his
creator closer to the message of
Peace today we have in the world various
games which are meant to entertain the
child Islam is for entertainment but the
entertainment should be Halal it should
be positive it should not be
negative we have
today in the society we have games like
Lotto or
Lottery it's is nothing but gambling
which Islam prohibits in Surah ma
chapter number five verse number 90
Allah
says oh you who
believe most certainly intoxic and
gambling dedication of stones divination
of
arrows these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handiwork
that you may Prosper so we have to
substitute these games with Islamic
games there are some games which are
just normal it entertains a child but
does not get him closer to the message
of Truth we have gamees such as Snakes
and Ladders there's the Islamic version
which has been invented in UK
it is slopes and
ladders instead of start it is Bismillah
in the name of
God when you go a few blocks
ahead there it's mentioned that you have
been offering Salah daily you go up a
ladder there it is you are thanking your
creator almighty God few blocks ahead
you are disrespectful to your parents
you come down the slope Allah subhana wa
ta'ala is not happy with you
go a few blocks ahead you are reading
the Quran daily you go up a ladder you
are getting guidance from your creator
almighty God go a few blocks ahead you
have told a lie you come down a slope so
these games besides the child getting
entertained he is getting the message
that he should respect his parents he
should not tell a lie he should thank
almighty God
daily should acquire the guidance from
the last and final revelation of the
Quran so Islam is for entertainment but
the entertainment should be POS positive
there are games which I remember during
my
childhood the very famous game the
Monopoly or we have the trade in India
where it teaches a child how to become a
businessman buying and selling off land
here we have the Islamic version called
the steps to
Paradise which has been got from UK too
here it teaches the child how to attain
jna how to attain Paradise
and instead of dollars or rupees you
have Saabs notes 5,000 Saab 10,000 Saab
20,000
Saab there you come on the slot it says
that you have offered Salah daily you
get a reward of 20,000 Saab to go a few
blocks ahead you went to a dance party
you have to pay a fine of 10,000
Saab go a few blocks ahead you have told
a lie you have to pay a fine of 5,000
Saab every child wants to win the
game so if you go for dance parties
everyone knows he goes he stops going so
that at least he can win the game these
games besides entertaining the child it
gets him closer to the Creator almighty
God there are jsaw puzzles of great
wonders of the world I feel T Taj man
Etc we have jigaw puzzle of the har of
Makkah of Madina we have Legos where a
child learns to make a car or airplane
here we have
Legos in which a child can build the
various mosques the different designs of
mosque with the Lego he builds a mosque
so he comes closer to the Hadith that
anyone who builds a mosque in this world
will get a house in the Jenna this is a
unique event not only in India but
internationally only those people who
know the value of the media and
presenting Islam only a DI can know that
believe me this is the need of the
AR this is the need of the AR it's the
duty of us Muslims that we have to
clarify the
misconceptions that is there in the
minds of the human beings today it's our
duty that we have to convey the message
Allah says in the Quran in Al Iman
chapter number 3 verse number 110 Allah
says
n oh Muslims ye are the best of people
evolved for mankind Allah is giving us
an honor and calling us the best of
people there is no honor without
responsibility the responsibility is
mentioned the same verse Allah continues
and
says because we enjoying what is good
and we forbid what is wrong and we
believe in
Allah the reason Allah calls us the um
the best of people is because we are
supposed to enjoy what is good and
forbid what is wrong and believe in
Allah if we do not enjoying what is good
and if we do not forbid what is wrong we
aren't fit to be called as Muslims we
aren't fit to be called as people those
who promote peace and submit the will to
almighty God we are't fit to be called
as the best people for Humanity today
when we present Islam we have to do it
professionally and a beloved prophet and
be pleased with him they always stressed
on
quality we require quality work the
reason today the
Muslims are misrepresented on the media
is because we do not have the correct
presentation on the media we don't have
a single international newspaper of our
own which can present the two picture of
Islam Islam and Muslims and it
derivatives these words occur in the
Quran no less than 90 six
times and the word Salam occurs in the
Quran no less than 42 times Islam and
Muslims along with the derivatives
occurs 96 times and the word Salam
occurs 42
times and Allah says in the Quran inam
chapter number 6 verse number 54 Allah
says when those who come to you who
believe in our signs wish them assalam
alayum peace be on you Allah says
whenever those who come to you who
believe in the signs of almighty God you
have to wish them peace be on you Allah
says in the Quran inaha chapter number
four verse number 86 Allah
says which means whenever a courteous
greeting is given to you wish back more
courteously or at least the
same for Allah is careful in keeping of
accounts for example if someone wishes
you assalamu alaykum may peace be on you
you have to wish back more
courteously if someone
says you have to wish back more
courteously if someone says
if you cannot better it at least say the
same may peace mercy and blessings of
Allah subh beond all of you for example
if someone says assalam Alum and reply
like the words are the same but that's
coming from the depths of the heart even
that is better so Allah says wish back
more courteously or it Le the same this
is the universal greeting of all the
messengers of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
even Jesus Christ peace be upon him it's
mentioned the Gospel of Luke chapter
number 24 verse number 36 in the upper
room when he comes to the apostles he
wishes them by saying shalam alum in
Hebrew shalam alaykum in Arabic assalam
alaykum in English may peace be on you
and this is the theme of the conference
Salam peace it's the best form of
greeting but unfortunately today we have
in a society the different different
types of
greeting one of the most common greeting
is good morning or good evening imagine
if suppose there's a Calamity which
takes place if someone's father dies and
you wish him good morning what is so
good about the morning his father has
expired and you tell him good
morning and when you go to school it's
common
practice when the teacher enters the
class all the students say good morning
sir and the teacher replies back good
morning to you imagine the teacher may
have had a fight with his wife he may be
cursing the morning he may be saying
never such a morning should come again
in the life but yet he's forced to reply
good
morning the best and the most universal
greeting is assalam alayum or peace be
on you irrespective whether a person's
father expires irrespective whether a
person has a fight with his wife
irrespective whether in cats and dogs
irrespective whether it's a happy moment
or a sad moment the best greeting you
can give is assalam alaykum peace be on
you and Allah says in the
Quran in Surah fan chapter number 25
verse number 63 that the Servants of
Allah are those who walk with humility
and when the ignorant approach them they
say peace be on you Allah repeats the
message
in Surah kasas chapter number 28 verse
number 55 that those who give vain
talks just tell them peace be on you
assalamu alaykum means a person who's
intelligent if person gives ve talk even
if he speaks again Islam tell
himay or say peace be on you that's
it and if you
analyze all the verses quoted by the
Skeptics attacking Islam that Islam
promotes
terrorism and one of the common verses
of the Quran quoted by critics including
Arun
shui Surah chter number 9 verse number
five it says wherever you find a kaf
into bracket a
non-muslim you kill them the reply to
this has been given by me when I came to
chenai last year on the topic Jihad and
terrorism I don't reply it again it's in
context in a battlefield when the
enemies come to kill you don't get
scared fight back the context is is
there I've discussed in several of my
talks and question on session but the
point to be noted the next verse
immediately Surah Toba chapter number 9
verse number six which is never quoted
by these Skeptics is that if the enemies
want Asylum if they want peace don't
just give it to them escort them to a
place of
security so all the vers if you analyze
almost all which
talk
about killing the enemies
but natural this fighting with the Quran
speaks is to promote peace and the
common verse quoted of the Quran of
Surah anfal chapter number 8 verse
number 60 that cause Terror in the
hearts of the
enemies again quote out of context it
means that in the battlefield when the
enemies come to attack you when they
come to kill you don't get scared fight
back any army General in the battlefield
will tell his soldiers don't get scared
fight back it's but natural so what's
wrong in Quran saying that but that's
not the end of it next ver Surah Anar
chapter number 8 verse number 61 says
but if the enemies want peace if they
inclin for peace you too incline for
peace Islam is a religion of
peace all these verses quoted in the
Quran wherever it talks about fighting
as the last resort it is fighting for
peace to be established every
country has a police force this police
force many a times use his
Force so that the criminals can be
arrested Ed they use Force against the
antisocial element so that peace can
Prevail so that we people citizens of
the country can walk freely to these
police sometimes use his Force so that
peace will prevail in the country
similarly Islam and Quran talks that
force can be used as a last resort only
to let peace Prevail if
this is why the Skeptics say that Quran
promotes terrorism they fail to realize
that such terrorism is even promoted by
the Bible in the Old Testament in the
book of Exodus in the Book of Numbers
Jesus Christ peace be upon him he too
promoted this terrorism Gospel of Luke
chapter number 22 he too told the
apostles take a sword go and
fight Mahabharat talks about the same
terrorism it's a fight between the H and
the B truth and falsehood bhagwat Gita
Shri Krishna he gives advice to Arjun
that why are you not fighting have you
become
important SRI Krishna tells Arjun if you
don't fight you shall not get
Paradise this is a terrorism to promote
peace which is mentioned almost all the
major scriptures of the
world there are two types of terrorism
one is a positive terrorism to promote
peace in the world the other is
terrorizing the innocent people which we
Muslims should never indulge
and Dr Adam Pearson said that people
worry that one day nuclear weaponry will
fall in the hands of the Arabs they fail
to realize that the Islamic bomb has
already been dropped it fell the day
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
born Islam this
religion has the solution to the
problems of humankind
and this last and final revelation of
almighty God has the solutions to the
problems of
mankind number one is that all the human
beings should agree that our
creator is only one God only if we agree
that the creator of all the people IR
respect of whether they live in America
in Canada in UK in India in Saudi Arabia
our creator is the same one almighty God
this is the basic pillar for
peace Quran says in Sur MAA chapter
number five verse number 32 that if
anyone kills any human being unless it
be for murder or spreading Mischief in
the land it is as though he has killed
the whole of humanity and if anyone
saves an human being it is as though he
has saved the whole of humanity Quran
says anyone whether Muslim or UNM Muslim
kills any other human being whether
Muslim or non-muslim unless it be for
murder or for spreading Mischief in the
land for spreading corruption it is as
though he has killed the whole of
humanity and if anyone saves the human
being whether it be a Muslim or
non-muslim it is as though he saved the
whole of
humanity Allah says in the Quran that
you should give charity every rich
person who has a saving of more than the
nisab level 85 gr of gold you should
give
2.5% of that saving every lunar year in
charity is called a zakat if every Rich
human being gives zakat poverty will be
eradicated there will not be a single
human being who will die of
hunger Quran says do not Rob Quran says
that love your neighbors feed your
neighbors AB Prophet said that he is not
a
Muslim who sleeps with a full stomach
while his
neighbor he is hungry and the person
asked who is a neighbor the prophet said
40 houses next to you is a neighbor